how's it going everybody what's going on
what's it like to be that muscular and
big
oh it's uh just like everything else you
just gotta eat a little more
isn't it great though when you walk down
the street you don't fear any man do you
no no i fear everybody i'm a pencil neck
my goodness and he's not you know blown
out of proportion he's you know
no that's i've yeah they're good to me
he is
you never juiced you able to get that
way on your own yeah absolutely i
started working out when i was 12 years
old
because you got beat up a lot right
exactly is that true i was uh
i was really just um pennsylvania yeah
and it was a true comic book story i was
getting beat up every day in junior high
i finally started working out and
hit the gym yeah learned some
self-defense not even
just that that is a pretty intimidating
thing
play football yeah exactly was it easy
for you to get big like that or
no no as a matter of fact it was a while
i i started really seeing results i
started
working out seriously at 12 years old
why don't i see results why don't i get
i'm in the gym every well i tell
everybody just to just stick with it a
lot of people will go to the gym
really strong for a month or three
months or even six months
for 20 years i've been doing it for just
about 20 years myself
and what about what about what what do
you do do you run at all or no i don't
do anything
is that how you get big well for me it's
just it it's it
work it's what works for me i mean
everybody's body is different you know
and and some people weren't meant to
carry a lot of body weight and a lot of
muscle mass and i i got big hands big
wrists big feet
so look at that belt that is you are the
world champion this is the wwe
championship yeah
you are you're now into the movie star
thing that's why you're here yeah we got
the movie coming out the marine yep
if your movie does well yeah and it
probably will because uh it's an action
film and you have a built-in audience
we know that uh vince mcmahon who is the
founder of the wwe
he's the big cheese he is the guy he
will own your name
he will he gets a cut of all of your
movies right absolutely is that the way
it works
with the rock tall man does that bother
you absolutely not
should he is he entitled to a cut of
your movie action absolute howard before
this
i was a kid in a small massachusetts
town
mowing lawns for a golf course i don't
mind kicking a percentage of my uh my
earnings to the person who gave me a
chance and an opportunity
vince in a sense is your sensei he's the
one who really
if anything that's a that's a sign of
respect i owe that guy a lot and you're
grateful
is he own of yours though that's my
government name he owns what's called
intellectual property right he owns john
cena
absolutely that's not your real name no
that's my government name
and he owns it well it's it's a weird
concept but in a way yeah
he owns the in other words you won't be
able to be yourself if you leave vince
yeah which is kind of cool i can get
another identity so this is a good life
it really is it's a different life
because you're not working a typical
nine to five so
i don't have a family life i'm not
married i'm not settled down i'm home
one two days a month so i mean you're on
the road and you're traveling so with
where is home home for me as us when uh
when the weather is good in new england
i spend time in new england when it's
bad i go to florida
what makes it about you that you became
the guy i think you took over the rock i
honestly that's
everybody's been saying that it's just
believability i am not afraid to one
make an ass myself and two go out there
and be myself how do you make an ass out
of yourself
well it's a lot of guys like oh i'd
never do that or ah you know they want
to be the quintessential tough guy
everybody wants to be a superhero i
don't mind
enjoying the entertainment aspect of it
let me ask something about the belt
it's all pre-arranged who's going to win
yeah our program is world wrestling
entertainment we do the we
we do what we do for the sake of
entertainment why do you carry around
i mean because you really didn't because
it has a huge wwe logo on it so if
anybody sees me walking around they know
they know who i work for why do you
think he became a wrestler was your dad
a wrestler
no but he was a huge wrestling fan and
do you think he did it to please him
no i just he really kind of forced us to
watch wrestling as kids i come from a
house of five boys
and he was i mean he was a true
disciplinary dad every anytime we were
bad we got the strap
we got our ass beat for misbehavin but
the one time
we could really just beat the hell out
of each other with no consequences
was a wrestling with someone so i i grew
up with the nwa the wwf then the awa it
was just something that
we all had we had we had like a little
ring set up in our basement see someone
told me your dad was a wrestling
announcer
believe it or not after i gained a
little bit of steam in the wwe my dad
with my same name john cena then got
involved in the business is he johnny
fabulous
he's johnny i told him if you used john
cena vincent kill him right
i see i see so so now he is still around
it's not uh oh of course yeah he's still
around
look at you man yeah you're the hero of
the family i'm trying to get the belt
and beat him now i'm trying what are the
other brothers doing
i got uh two brothers that are a cop one
who's a professional loafer and one that
works in the tech industry
yeah how do you get that loafing job
what do you mean he is the tail end he's
the youngest brother the guy who kind of
like after you have five boys it's like
oh we got another one do you give him
money
uh is that what you're saying if uh if
he needs to be hooked up i hook him up
are you a millionaire now
uh i'm i'm eating right i'm doing all
right i'm doing all right
well uh john i wish you luck with this
uh thank you very much this is a big
deal for you
not only a big deal for me but a big
deal for the wwe brand this is a wwe
film